Right.
Well,
I want to turn to date to some of the political developments of the early 17th
century.
Um,
in reading about and discussing the Tudor monarchy,
we've looked at the development of a political system,
which was in many ways highly centralized,
but at the same time increasingly participatory and consultative.
In certain matters of state,
the royal will was supreme and the prerogative power of the monarch was
paramount.
And yet as Marcus Lansky says,
the constitutional position was that monarchical power was limited by the
evolution of its practice.
The progress of power of the prince could not override the liberties of the
subject enshrined in law.
And the Monica was also expected to have an eye to the views and the interests
of the broader political nation.
Those who govern the localities and who acted in a sense as brokers between the
royal administration and the nation at large.
Well to that important extent,
the effectiveness of government and the maintenance of political stability
depended on the relationships between the crown and the political nation
as we move into the 17th century.
The essential point of grasp perhaps is that these relationships were never
fixed.
They can turn it contained,
certain gray areas.
There were certain tensions,
certain ambiguities,
and there was nothing new about that.
From time to time they'd surfaced under Elizabeth and they'd been on the whole
handled and resolved.
In the final analysis,
the interests of the crown and the political nation,
we're expected to run together and there was also a strong emphasis in the
political culture of the time on trying to achieve harmony and consensus.
Open conflict was regarded as a sign of failure in the political process
and yet despite all of that,
in the mid 17th century,
that system collapsed.
In 1642 civil war broke out between the crown and the parliament.
In 1649 King Charles the first was put on trial by a High Court of justice
formed from parliament and executed and the republic was declared,
which lasted for over a decade
now.
These were political events of quite extraordinary radicalism for the 17th
century,
kings had been deposed and replaced in the past.
Kings had been killed in battle.
Kings had sometimes been murdered by rival claimants but never before had a
reigning monarch,
been formally put on trial and called to account and then executed as Oliver
Cromwell.
One of the movers of that act put it,
we cut off the king's head with the crown on it.
We cut off the king's head with the crown on it by which he meant that they had
tried and executed not just a man,
but an institution,
the institution of Monarchy.
Well such a momentous events perhaps imply very profound causes and as a result,
the political history of the early 17th century has traditionally been reviewed,
been viewed as in many respects a high road to civil war.
That's a phrase which is often used
in looking at the development of the situation.
Traditionally the the so called Wig variant of the story tells a tale of an
assertive parliament increasingly anxious to defend its privileges and worried
about the liberties of the subject coming into conflict with monarchs who were
trying to extend the sphere of royal prerogative par.
And as a result,
parliament fought back by demanding greater influence on policy.
That's the essentials of the traditional story.
There's a Marxist variant on that too,
which argues that behind these political developments behind the assertiveness
of parliament was a growth in the social and economic power of the gentry and of
the urban elites of the country.
People who had done well out of economic change and we're seeking a greater
place in the sun expressing their aspirations in a developing rhetoric of the
liberties of the subject.
In the 1970s and 1980s however,
a more conservative so called revisionist school of historians rejected these
interpretations of the high road to civil war and began arguing that they were
essentially the product of hindsight in the view of this school,
there was no deep rooted malaise in the English body politic.
No great clash of fundamental constitutional principles,
no high road to civil war.
Rather,
as they tell the story,
the catastrophe of the 1640s was the result of short term misjudgments and
unforeseen contingent circumstances.
Almost a tragic accident.
The one which came to have very profound consequences.
Well,
there's no need to rehearse all the details of these debates at length.
If they interest you.
Then the introduction to custom Hughes's book conflict in early steward England
is an excellent overview of the way the historiography has developed,
but these debates continue and they continue in a sense because the English
civil wars are still being fought on paper because the 17th century was a
defining moment in British political history.
Nevertheless,
at the moment we seem to be in a phase of what's sometimes described as post
revisionism in which historians of the period are increasingly willing to
recognize the merits of different arguments.
First of all,
that the traditional interpretation was perhaps a little too teleological and
that the role of short term contingency was neglected in that story,
but on the other hand,
recognizing that in its more extreme manifestations,
revisionism is almost willfully short sighted as an interpretation above all,
it fails to take account of the larger context of political life in the nation
and of the changing social and cultural context within which politics took
place.
As a result.
It's been said by some critics that the revisionist approach tends to explain
why the English civil war shouldn't have happened,
but they did.
It happen.
They can't explain why people felt so passionately that they were willing to
draw a sword against their fellow countrymen.
So we mustn't assume a particular preordained direction of events.
We mustn't imply an inevitability about the process.
We have to be alive to the importance in politics of contingent circumstances
and the interventions of specific individuals,
but at the same time we have to remain aware of the fact that short term
conflict can have a cumulative effect and politics was not conducted in a social
or ideological vacuum.
Well,
to stand back from that for a moment and bring the story through from the acs
session of James,
the first one thing one can say with certainty and that's that in 1,603 when
King James came down from Scotland and was crowned King of England,
no one anticipated the trouble that was to come.
On the contrary,
the mood of the political nation in 1,603 was by and large one of celebration.
They had an adult,
adult Monique and experience king who ruled well in Scotland.
He was a from Protestant and he had two sons.
Everything looked great
given the nature of the political system,
the tone of James's rain dependent very much upon the personality of the Monique
and James on the whole.
What's capable of negotiating the ambiguities of the constitutional situation
pretty well?
There was certainly some in his relationships with parliament when it was cold.
The English parliament,
very aware of James's unfamiliarity with its system was jealous of its
privileges,
anxious that the new Monique should be brought to understand them correctly as
it sold them.
It was rather critical of the king's use of his prerogative power to raise
customs revenues by so called impositions on trade and at the same time it was
deeply suspicious of any financial innovation which might make the crown more
independent of parliament.
In 1610 for example,
parliament rejected plans for what was called the great contract,
which would have granted to the king irregular annual taxation income in return
for abolishing certain antiquated and archaic futile revenues.
It failed.
They were too anxious to maintain control of the purse for it to go through
on the king's part.
James had a very high conception of his royal prerogative.
He regarded the privileges of parliament has having been granted by his
ancestors in the past for particular purposes,
rather than being fundamental features of a mythical ancient constitution.
As some members of parliament believed,
he was certainly not used to having such an independent minded body as the
English parliament.
Scotland had a parliament,
but it was very much under the control of the king.
He was prone to times to lecturing the members of parliament when he believed
them to have encroached upon his sovereignty.
But of course,
Elizabeth had done that in her time.
James was also ready to use his power to dissolve parliament when he became
exasperated with it.
And certainly he didn't call it very often.
But nevertheless,
if James had any pretensions to absolute power,
they were strictly theoretical.
Uh,
he is once recorded as having told these Spanish ambassador in a conversation
that he marveled,
that his ancestors had created such a body as the English parliament,
but he had founded in being when he came to the throne and he was obliged to put
up with what he couldn't get rid of.
And so he did like the shrewd and Kenny Monique that he was
more broadly,
if there were those amongst the political nation who were a little disappointed
with King James after the early years,
once the honeymoon was over,
who came to dislike the sometimes rather sleazy tone of his court who disliked
his fondness for favorites or his notorious financial extravagance.
Nonetheless,
there's no reason to believe that the consensual political system was under any
unusual strain during James as rain,
but if that was the case,
it didn't survive.
The 1620s
1620s turned out to be a decade of mounting crisis and acute political
polarization.
A polarization which was vividly reflected in the relations between crown and
parliament
and this situation arose from a combination of factors,
partly involve foreign policy difficulties.
It partly involves religion.
It partly involved in engagement in war and taxation,
perceived threats to the common law,
and it all came to a focus on the person of one man,
George Villiers,
the Duke of Buckingham,
not Buckingham,
was a handsome young man,
rather charismatic by all accounts who had come to court and attracted James the
first attention.
In the late 1610s becoming favorite of the king.
He had been rapidly advanced two titles and to Fortune
well had he just been James's toy boy,
this would not have mattered very much.
The total was bucking him,
was anxious to exercise power by the early 1620s he not only held high office,
but he was also using his position to become increasingly dominant in the
control of royal patronage.
With all that that meant moreover,
his ascendancy well established in the later years of King James survived the
old king's death bucking him also dazzled Prince Charles and retained his
position as royal favorite.
When Charles came to the throne in 1625 by 60 and 28 he appears to have had
virtually a monopoly over influence on policy together with that,
his manifest in competence rendered him odious in the eyes of the political
nation.
So Redwood Cook,
the Lord Chief Justice Describe Buckingham as the grievance of grievances.
He was beginning to be seen in the eyes of some of the political nation as the
quintessential bad counselor.
So Buckingham came to provide something of a focus for deteriorating relations
between the crown and the political nation.
But the broad context for that deterioration was provided by other events,
notably events in Europe,
the outbreak and 1618 of the 30 years' war,
the expulsion from his lands of James,
the first son in law,
the Protestant elector of the palatinate,
and the triumphant advance in the 1620s of the Catholic forces of the Habsburg
monarchs of Austria and Spain events,
which were very anxiously followed by many English gentleman as as we've seen,
it was essentially the question of England's potential involvement or actual
involvement in this European crisis,
which led to the summoning of so many parliaments in the 1620s and it was the
conduct of affairs under Buckingham,
which led members of parliament increasingly to try to exert greater influence
over matters,
which were strictly speaking matters for the royal prerogative.
And that was a situation which began the slide into confrontation.
To sum it all up briefly,
there were five parliaments between 1621 and 1629 three of them were dissolved
acrimoniously after quarrels between the king and parliament.
On three occasions,
the king acrimoniously dissolve parliament and sent them home.
The cause of all this was parliaments attempts to exert influence on policy in
provocative matters of state as the king saw them.
Matters of foreign policy matters concerning the marriage of Prince Charles
matters concerning the choice of royal and ministers to conduct policy and
matters concerning religion.
This developing atmosphere of conflict was made worse when after 60 and 26 king
Charles resorted to measures of questionable the galaxy in order to sustain his
policies and such.
Conflict was fought out in parliament after parliament through assertions of
parliamentary privilege and constitutional principle,
which were met by the use of the royal prerogative to dissolve parliament and
silence critics of royal policy.
That's the essence of it all,
but let's run through some of these sort of edited highlights of what happened
in these parliaments.
The essence of it all is on your handout.
In 1621 parliament was called to grant money for some form of action to support
the Protestant elector Palatine,
King James,
his son in law parliament,
voted a modest subsidy to support armies for the Platter Nate,
but also petitioned James to declare war on Spain and to abandon the plans which
he had formed to marry Prince Charles to a Spanish princess and to assure assure
a protestant marriage.
Instead,
King James was furious.
His plan for a marriage with Spain was part of a larger scheme to try to end the
polarization within Europe.
It was part of his scheme for secure good relations with Spain,
which might help forward and negotiated settlement and their withdrawal of
Spanish troops and he forbade the Commons to meddle in this grand design.
The Commons responded by declaring that the king was interfering with,
I'm quoting the ancient liberty of parliament for freedom of speech.
The same being our ancient and undoubted right,
and an inheritance received from our ancestors.
James replied to their liberty or free speech was derived from the grace and
permission of our ancestors and us and should not be abused by the parliament.
In matters of state.
There was uproar.
The House of Commons composed of protest,
the so called protestation saying that their privileges,
what the ancient and undoubted birthright and inheritance of the subjects of
England games responded by dissolving parliament and he personally ripped the
Prato station from the Journal of the House of Commons.
Well,
James did not go to war with Spain as parliament desired,
and he persisted with his plans for Spanish marriage.
In 1623 Prince Charles accompanied by Buckingham went to Spain in order to woo
the Spanish princess Di and Fanta.
This occasioned massive anxiety in England,
followed by widespread public rejoicing.
When the marriage negotiations eventually fell through
humiliated by their failure,
Charles and Buckingham now began to exert their influence to back the idea of
war with Spain.
In 1624 parliament was called again.
It voted money to the crown,
but withheld the finance bill until war was reluctantly declared by King James
and England entered the war in alliance with France and alliance,
which involved the marriage of Prince Charles to the French Princess Henrietta
Maria sister of the King of France,
a Catholic who arrived in England with a Catholic entourage,
including priests and confessors.
In 1625 Charles came to the throne.
He was now age 25 parliament met at the beginning of the rain as was customary
and voted money for the continuation of the war,
but it failed to grant the king the usual grant of customs revenue for life.
This was because parliament was unhappy about recent customs in positions which
didn't have parliamentary sanction.
In September of that year,
September of 1625 the Duke of Buckingham led an English naval expedition to
attack the Spanish port of Cadiz,
attempting to emulate the great feat of Francis Drake when he had attack kudus
and a 50 and eighties but Buckingham was not Francis Drake.
His expedition was an utter failure demonstrating gross military in competence
on the part of the Duke.
Okay.
Following that humiliation.
In 1626 parliament met again to provide money for the war.
It proved willing to vote supply to the ground crown,
but it demanded that it's grievances should be rectified.
Before the finance bill was finally passed
and the grievances were above all a torrent of hostility towards Buckingham and
other new counselors influencing the king,
notably the Armenian bishops who have been brought into the privy council.
The Commons proceeded to try to draw up articles of impeachment against bucking
him for his incompetence.
Charles attempted to hold them by illegally imprisoning several members of the
House of Commons,
and when that failed,
he again dissolved parliament in order to save the Duke from impeachment
proceedings.
No money was granted
in need of money to finance the war.
Charles and Buckingham now decided to levy a massive forced loan.
They simply levied what was officially alone,
in fact,
an illegal tax on the tax paying section of the political nation,
claiming the king's right to do this by prerogative power in conditions of
national emergency.
Over 70 members of the gentry refused to pay and we're imprisoned by the kings.
Special Commandment.
Again,
a use of prerogative power in prison without trial to make matters worse,
bucking him now secured a declaration of war not only against Spain,
but against France also,
and squandered the force loan money by leading another disastrous naval
expedition.
This time to aid French Protestants who were rebelling against Louis the 13th of
France in the city of La Rochelle on the coast of south west France,
another military disaster.
This deteriorating situation finally came to a head in 1628 to nine parliament
was called again again to raise money and it met in an ominous mood.
So Benjamin,
Roger at one of the members declared,
this is the crisis of parliaments.
We feel no by this,
whether parliaments shall live or die.
The House of Commons started by promising,
devote the king of large sum of money,
but again insisted that their grievances should be heard.
Before the finance bill was finalized,
again,
there was a torrent of complaint concerning grievances arising from the forced
loan and the conduct of the war under Buckingham.
And finally,
all of this was encapsulated in the so called petition of right,
the petition of right,
which was presented to the king requesting that he confirmed the liberties of
the subject threatened by the recent conduct off his government.
Specifically,
there should be no taxation without parliamentary consent.
There should be no arbitrary arrest of subjects.
There should be no billeting of troops upon subjects without their consent.
There should be no government of the localities by Marshall Law,
which is something which had occurred in the areas of the kingdom where troops
were billeted prior to Buckingham's expedition
in order to get the necessary money.
Charles reluctantly agreed to the petition of right though insisting that in
doing so,
he was not surrendering any of his prerogative powers.
That was in June,
1628 parliament then adjourned and went into recess and before it met again,
the Duke of Buckingham was assassinated in August,
1628 by one of his former officers and event,
which was greeted by almost universal public rejoicing throughout England.
One of the few exceptions to that rejoicing being King Charles himself,
who was profoundly grieved by the loss of his friend and deeply bitter about the
way Buckingham's murder had been greeted with virtual dancing in the streets
throughout the kingdom.
In January,
1629 parliament reconvened and attempted to press it's advantage there was a
vigorous attack upon the recently promoted Armenian bishops in the church who
were accused of introducing Polish innovations.
As we heard last time,
there was the use of the petition of right to attack the illegality of Charles's
collection of customs,
which he had continued to collect despite the fact that parliament had not
confirmed it's grant of customs revenue.
Charles decided to halt parliament's sitting in this situation,
but when the speaker of the House of Commons was told to announce the
dissolution of parliament to the Commons,
he was held down in his chair by several the members.
They refused to allow him to announce the dissolution.
The door of the House of Commons was shut against the Kings Messenger and barred
until the Commons led by Sir John Elliot put forward three resolutions to the
house.
First of all,
the resolution that anyone furthering Potpourri or are many aneurysm was to be
considered a capital enemy to this kingdom.
Secondly,
that whoever advised the king to collect customs revenue without parliamentary
consent would also be considered a capital enemy to the kingdom.
Thirdly,
that anyone paying these duties was an enemy to the liberties of England.
These three resolutions were passed by acclamation in the House of Commons and
Charles responded by dissolving parliament.
It didn't meet again for 11 years.
Now it's been suggested in recent years that we shouldn't really make too much
of all of this,
that the conflict that scarred political life in the 1620s was sporadic rather
than continuous,
that it was a product of particular circumstances in the conduct of the wars in
particular rather than a reflection of growing ideological division,
that consensual values still held their power,
that the leaders of parliament did not constitute an organized and coherent
opposition to the crowd.
These arguments need to be taken seriously,
but for myself,
I can say I don't really find them convincing.
Certainly the conflict did arise from the contingent circumstances surrounding
particular meetings of parliament and certainly the members of the political
nation would have preferred a consensual relationship with the royal government
that they repeatedly showed their willingness to grant the taxes necessary for
the war on certain conditions.
They would have liked to establish a new consensus,
but the 1620s had also witnessed the enmeshing of a variety of sources of
discontent with Charles has government.
The political nation was becoming seriously divided over a number of fundamental
issues which recur repeatedly and an ideological Fisher was emerging over
certain key questions such as the extent to which the king's prerogative powers
were or were not limited by law.
The scope of parliaments,
legitimate role in advising the crown and representing the views of the
political nation.
The question of whether the principle of taxation by consent would be maintained
or not.
The question of whether the ecclesiastical policy being pursued by the crown
with the appointment of Armenian bishops was or was not undermining English
Protestantism.
Now,
all of those issues which do recur add up to a pretty heady mixture.
It's a formidable cocktail of anxieties.
And as you know,
these anxieties were widely shared,
well outside the confines of the houses of parliament,
widely shared by a broad and growing political public,
which was informed by novel means of political news reporting,
which emphasized not consensus but danger and conflict.
The emergence of a broad public opinion which expected parliament to act to
remedy it's concerns with shorty something which was part and parcel of the
deterioration of relationships between the crown and the political nation at
large.
And the fact that not all of those who learned of what was happening at the
center,
we're necessarily sympathetic to parliament,
deepened the emerging political division in the country.
No one who took a serious interest in political affairs at this time could
really fail to be aware that there was something of a functional breakdown in
the consensual political system by the latest 1620s and of course they had to
explain to themselves what was going on.
Um,
two influential interpretations of that by Peter Lake and Jonathan Scott have
argued that people explain the situation to themselves with reference to what
have been described as too similar but mutually exclusive conspiracy theories
to those who sympathized with parliament and particular to the leaders at the
House of Commons,
Lexa,
John Elliot or John Pym.
The erosion of consensus was attributable to what they described as a pope ish
plot amongst evil counselors of the crown who are hostile to English
Protestantism and to the liberties of the subject.
And two were favor favorable to absolutism or arbitrary power in both church and
state.
They associated together popery and arbitrary power,
which was to prove a dominant theme in 17th century English,
oppositional politics.
That Association of affairs in Church and state popery and arbitrary power was
already being made.
That was one conspiracy theory.
On the other hand amongst people who recoiled from what they had begun to see as
parliaments accesses
especially the scenes in 1629 the fault lay not with crypto papers to round the
king,
but with what they described as popular spirits,
popular spirits,
populists,
radicals who failed to respect the proper legitimate rights of the crown and who
were making constitutional encroachments upon them and who's attempts to achieve
greater popularity in government were linked to a preference for popularity in
religion also,
which is to say they saw them as Crypto,
Presbyterians,
puritans,
popular spirits.
That was the view of those who swung increasingly to the king's side in these
corals.
But with the dissolution of Parliament in 1629 the forum for the public
expression of the first of these sets of anxieties had been removed.
Parliament was no longer there,
and the conduct of government lay with people like archbishop laud or Thomas
Wentworth,
the Earl of Strafford who shared.
The second view went with in particular was a man who had been vehemently
opposed as a member of parliament to the Duke of Buckingham,
but who recoiled in 1629 from what he took to be the excesses of parliament,
threatening the breakdown of order.
Lord and Wentworth proved strong allies of the king who himself of course took
the view that popular spirits were at work and was determined not to call
another parliament in which they could express their voice if he could possibly
avoid it.
So with the dissolution of 1629 to Charles and his advisors,
the 1630 is represented something of a fresh start
piece was made first of all,
with France in 1629 and then with Spain in 1630 in Europe,
the situation was becoming less threatening.
In 1629 the Protestant King of Sweden intervened in Germany and then in 1620
1635 France on the cardinal,
rich Leah intervened and together that greatly lessen the threat of Habsburg
domination and a triumphant counter-reformation
at home.
Charles was determined to close down the consultative and participate we
dimensions of the political process.
He believed that it had led only to obstruction,
disruption and conflict,
and he would have no more of it if possible,
but he was also determined to rule well according to his own lights.
In 1631 following the harvest crisis,
he is sued a book of orders which tightened up the administration of local
government with particular attention to the efficient enforcement of the poor
laws and a great deal was achieved in that respect.
Steps were also taken by the royal government to remedy some of the deficiencies
which had emerged in the course of Buckingham's.
Unsuccessful military campaigns in the 1620s steps were taken to reform the
militia to institute the training to a higher level of military preparedness of
part of the militia and steps.
We're also instituted to rebuild and strengthen the navy.
All of these things were very much to the king's credit and yet in other
respects he can be said to have confirmed some of the worst fears of his
opponents in 1629
as you know,
Arminianism continued to be ruthlessly promoted in the church and the archbishop
laud who became Archbishop of Canterbury.
Of course in 1633 in the absence of parliamentary grants of taxation,
the king also resorted to a variety of financial expedience which would have
questionable legality.
There were many of these.
One for example,
was so called district of Knighthood.
By this,
the king revived an ancient feudal law under which landholders have a certain
level of wealth.
We're fined if they didn't present themselves before the king to be made nights.
He was digging up a medieval precedent in order to squeeze money out of certain
members of the landed.
Gentry was deeply resented.
New Customs in positions were introduced.
Of course without parliamentary sanction.
Efforts were made to search for and revive any royal rights over land,
which could be sources of income by obliging landholders to meet compositions
with the king in order to have royal rights relaxed again,
digging into the medieval past for precedents which could be exploited fiscally
above all,
the king levied from 1634 the tax ship money just to explain ship money was
attacks which could be levied on coastal counties and on ports in lieu of their
provision of ships for the Royal Navy.
In time of need.
It was well established.
It had been used by Elizabeth in the war against Spain without any complaint.
Charles Harvard took things further.
He charged ship money on the ports,
initially extended it to coastal counties in time of peace.
And then in 1635 extended it to the entire country.
Thereafter,
ship money was levied every year it had become an annual unparliamentary tax.
The legality of ship money was challenged in 1637 by a number of gentlemen who
refuse to pay led by John Hamden after Houma,
our suburb is named and ship money was only narrowly validated in the court
judgement,
which resulted in the ship money case where the judges found for the king,
but only by a majority of seven to five only narrowly did they recognize the
legality of this tax.
Five of the principal justices thought it was illegal.
Well,
to revisionist historians,
the 1630s can be seen as a period of relatively successful royal government.
Marcus Lansky has remarked that there was no ground swell of opposition to
Charles's government in the 1630s and indeed there was little public protest.
For the simple reason that there was no longer a forum for that protest to be
expressed since parliament was not meeting.
But if the 1630s where a period of apparent stability,
I'd suggest that it was the stability of resignation or the stability of anxious
waiting on events rather than active consent to these measures by the royal
government down in the counties.
Local rulers usually obeyed royal commands when they received them,
it was their duty to do so,
but they could also entertain their private thoughts.
They could discuss them cautiously and anxiously with their neighbors.
They could record them privately in their diaries.
They could watch what happened in things like the ship money case in 1633 so
Robert Hardy entered in his diary,
his prayers for a new parliament as well as his prayers for Protestant success
in Europe and for the religious exiles in New England in the county of Suffolk.
John Ross is revealed by his diary to have been deeply worried,
deeply reluctant to think badly of the king,
sometimes defending the king's actions against more critical neighbors.
But by the end of the 1630s he too had become convinced that there existed
around the king,
what he described as a malignant party who hate reformation and would bring in
tyranny
amongst many of the political nation.
Then Charles ruler was breeding a profound anxiety,
a profound alienation,
deep suspicion regarding what his ultimate intentions might be.
The extent of that alienation would only be fully revealed when parliament met
again in 1640 when the king was at last obliged to call another parliament,
but that he did so at all was the consequence of his own folly,
the folly of Charles and Archbishop Lord in 1637 when they decided to impose
upon the Presbyterian Church of Scotland,
both an extension of Episcopal government and an English style prayer book,
it was an act of utter folly.
The product of their dogmatism,
that arrogance,
their insistence upon uniformity and the blow back was catastrophic.
When the Archbishop of St Andrews attempted to read from the new prayer book and
St Giles Cathedral in Edinburgh and Edinburgh housewife through her stool at him
to the Scots.
Such innovations in their church,
a separate church from the Church of England seem to be,
as they described them,
pope ish,
atheist,
tickle,
and English.
Which of the three was worst?
I leave to your judgement.
They met together in 1638 to form a national covenant to resist these
innovations.
And in the face of the king's refusal to back down,
they rebelled.
And by doing so began to cause the whole house of cards to fall.
And I'll take the story up from there next week.